thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here this is the Dave
Ramsey show where common sense is still
alive we declare it right here
officially man thanks for calling in
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five we still believe
old-fashioned values like there is a
right and a wrong there is stupid and
the other side of the coin is smart hey
there is a difference and well you can't
have your truth and I'll have mine
because you would be wrong that's how
this works there is a proper way to do
things there's a right way to raise your
kids there's a right way to be married
there's a right way to treat your
employees there's a right way to work
while you're at work
as an employee there's a right and a
wrong thing out there this relativism
crap has melted people into a pool of
stupidity and they cannot breathe
anymore it's crazy out there have you
noticed it's nuts not here we have to
shoo the dinosaurs out so we can get
into the studio because that's how old
we are and we still believe that those
old-fashioned values are real that in
order to be able to tell the truth you
would actually have to know what the
truth is you can't tell the truth if you
don't know what the truth is and if you
don't believe and if you believe you get
to make up your own truth then you're a
liar cuz you don't know the truth there
is a truth there are things that are
right and things that are wrong there
are things that work and things that do
not work and no you don't get to make up
your own reality just because you got a
trophy it's not how it works you will
continue to plant that stupidity and you
will continue to reap broke desperate
and scared there's a right way to do
things and a wrong way to do things and
we're going to tell you what they are
and then you'll have the option since
you're above 18 years old most of you to
do what you choose to do I'm not gonna
make you do anything I can't to start
with nor what I want that power but I'm
going to show you a
up by step process by which you can
change your entire life and that's where
common sense comes from common sense is
so uncommon that it is now deemed a
superpower hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind